you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on chess calm
and I just got paired up playing a 500
game against a logo so let's see what
team black throws at me
all righty and I go for something smooth
Bishop f4
make sure my dark square bishop splaying
and we're gonna tuck him back and say if
you take me I get the H file all right
let's get c4 in Knight c3 will black
play c5 right now or later or b6
all right c5 now let's just take may
look to saddle black with an isolated
pawn structure iqp if it turns
symmetrical I'm fine with that this
bishops making a lot of moves all right
they're trying to damage my structure to
play Queen b3 I would expect 94 well
it's just
are we doing this case well I'm gonna go
here I may end up gambling upon try to
play against the Queen Bishop this is a
piece that is likely to struggle some to
get activated maybe a bit off with
saying likely but all right Queen b3
just protect the knight for a little bit
let's let's do this I think I'm okay
with declaring my queen I don't want to
be too quick to just give up upon so it
is a developing move after all so one
move away before I connect rooks now
alrighty I guess we'll take with the
bishop hmm maybe I want to take with the
Queen actually yeah I'm gonna take with
the clean I'm preparing to maybe shift
over here I might I might look forward
to some Queen side attack now Bishop d7
right here Bishop d7 and rook to c8
they'll probably end up winning upon but
I'll have the bishop pair and probably a
nibble of compensation so I'm okay with
that
and make something happen so far even on
the clock knight c6 Bishop takes Knight
I don't know I I guess I could take with
the Queen okay so they're just going for
a quick maybe e4 do you have that
covered enough well actually why can I
not just take this pawn Bishop takes e5
what's the story with that that's
threatening the knight
I'm gonna have to show me I don't
understand that move
maybe what they overlooked is that I'm
defending the night gonna come over here
you know I think they maybe missed that
yeah this has definitely gone wrong here
cuz I could take the night and even take
here there's no for a second I was
thinking the Queen's opposite my queen I
could take another pawn and defend this
night okay are there any tactics here I
should maybe be on the lookout for that
now I mean just rip the heart out of
their kingside structure so Bishop takes
pawn King takes Knight g5 I don't think
there's enough but it's close
so let's consider moving forward my
queen is pretty stable you know let's
let's just go here move forward just
want to get castle Oh maybe Bishop here
I might have Knight g5 soon
Knight g5 next that's looking pretty
serious Bishop c4 is the only thing
that's something that stops me from
castling yeah there we go
so can't castle in either direction so
it's a little bit uncomfortable like g5
okay yeah maybe I should have just
played Bishop to e2 and made sure I got
castled so what I could do however is
force the Queen's off with Queen g5 and
I am up to pawns
is there a cleaner approach also in
under two minutes
[Music]
well I g5 how do they defend the bishop
takes h7 I'll roll the dice a little bit
I don't see how they really defend
against h7 Queen H a bishop takes h7
King f8 Queen h8
I don't know this was simpler all right
yeah there's that
well now I mean some
is trouble
yeah they could actually run out to e7 I
should have went for this simple
approach okay
well do I have anything no they got
everything covered check the King runs I
take the rook and then I want to get it
mated mm-hmm
should have been more practical all
right I think I have to do something
like this now
it's unfortunate pretty unfortunate what
do I have a broken two two ponds
I guess now or never get castled 39
seconds as well I should have just
played Queen g5 that was a good move I
guess the the threats going into the H a
were my queen was restricted having to
defend c3 yeah and that's good enough to
disrupt things if I take there's Bishop
takes name I'll just play out out a
little bit more for decision point there
clearly okay I guess I have to try and
keep things defended but this is clearly
busted and I'm going to be dropping a
bishop so let me just throw in the towel
right now mm-hmm
Queen g5 I'm a fan of Queen trades in
completely even positions and in the
position when I'm up to pawns I don't
want a Queen trade I guess I was seeing
maybe an attack that really was not
there is what it's coming down to it's
getting a little bit too ambitious so
let's just go through and see where
there's a quick improvement with this
one this is where I want to be okay and
I could highlight this squares I forgot
that last time so this opening stage
what to say it's pretty simple
development and then this is where
things heat up it's fine with D take C
Bishop takes Knight c3 Queen c2 I just
put play Bishop d3 which is fine you
know that wants to even go for a castles
here and I think there could be much
wrong with Queen b3 though or is there
hmm
okay so this is this is something I
could take away from this my decision to
play Queen b3 could be met with a quick
Knight d7 into c5 yeah and that is a bit
uncomfortable because it's not just
hitting the Queen but also my bishop so
that's definitely a correction it
suggested just Castle here in suppose
black goes in and is a bit greedy okay
takes and what's the story here
suppose suppose pawn takes okay what I
could have is Bishop to e5 damaging the
structure and keeping Queens on now I
did get that in the game right I damage
the structure but the the big drawback
is that I didn't complete development so
we're seeing here as I was voicing in
the game there is a way you know you
could play it where yeah you might lose
a queen side pawn but you know this guy
is the the one thing that I kind of I up
and say he's gonna struggle so therefore
I have a little bit of compensation I
still the lead in development okay so I
won't be playing Queen b3 next time
let's just get on with castle something
I failed to do in this game
and I was punished I also doesn't like
Queen takes
hmm wants to go with bishop takes here
okay well the Queen b3 idea is bad
altogether I played here and it would
suggest b6 or even b5 Wow okay I'm just
one move away but black is able to stir
up some trouble the ship is a little bit
not the most comfortable of pieces being
on an open file no both my queen and
bishop are on open file so you know
they're gonna have to find some new
homes in the foreseeable future and then
this is just a mistake I would think
yeah it's just giving me up on Bishop e6
Queen h4 is fine Bishop takes f6 oh my
goodness that's what for the books yeah
I think there's a better move here oh
man
well I saw h7 later I saw each seven
later oh I wonder how many commented
before I even got to the analysis point
didn't you didn't you have Queen takes
h7 at this point yeah this is a way to
end the game
checkmate ends the game oh man not too
often but yeah it does happen that you
overlook I'm a and one oh my goodness I
was just excited about winning upon oh
man okay still winning here but oh man
Queen takes h7 unbelievable
okay and I guess the last point here oh
it's okay with Bishop e4 I was thinking
after I played Bishop before in this
move was played I was like oh you know
maybe I should have just gone here and
then I could be assured that I'm gonna
castle soon is this okay
it's an okay move and I should be able
to complete development but it's fine
with this and what could I have done
better instead of Knight g5 Oh Bishop
takes h7 his working here when I played
Knight g5 is this losing I wonder
no it's not losing but what did I have
to play I played this King f8
I have the g7 square I didn't realize
that I had the g7 square this is still
uncomfortable though look at the wild
move the computers pointing out with 94
oh now it even finds a win for black so
this is this is a faulty decision to go
after the king like this but it does
like Bishop takes seif Bishop takes h7
here followed up with I imagine Knight
g5 Queen h4 Oh tactics tactics tactics
Queen h4 picking up the bishop lose
pieces
hmm and on Bishop takes King f8 i could
play Bishop f5 you know just to move
away and I missed meeting one oh that's
that's I don't know what more to say I'm
busted from here after I thought I had
to have to take the rook I simply didn't
see that I have a safe Square on g7 but
still but still apparently was some time
here computer I thought it was pointing
out Knight d4 right around this point
even it's saying Knight to e5 and this
is pretty scary
well it's bishops bearing down at my
king he wants to be safe but he's just
one move short Wow well I hope at the
very least this one was a little bit
entertaining maybe frustrating that here
he stopped me missing a mate one I'll
try to correct that yeah
back to basics we're gonna have to work
on some mate and want puzzles maybe for
the next video
oh man not too often but yeah you got to
see that one live I guess sort of anyhow
I helped again it was a little bit of
educational and probably a bit more
entertaining than anything frustrating I
don't know feel free to share your
thoughts on this one in the comment
section below and I hope you got
something out of it whether it was a
little education entertainment or maybe
a little of both
I don't know anyhow feedback is always
appreciated and hope you're having a
great day catch in the next video bye
bye
you
[Music]